[Music]
party be released her debut album
invasion of privacy on Friday but it's
not just her music making headlines
we're counting down five secrets from
the rapper since her album dropped
starting with her baby bombshell I don't
know if it's the strength of the fetus
but I have never feel so hungry to
secede after weeks of dodging rumors the
25 year old confirmed she's expecting a
baby with her rapper Bo offset by
wearing this form-fitting dress on
Saturday Night Live and her sister may
have revealed the baby's gender in a
congratulatory post on Instagram
screenshots seemed to show that Hennessy
Carolina's original caption read give
her all the kisses and hugs before it
was made gender-neutral cardi B admitted
the pregnancy was not planned and she
briefly considered having an abortion
kinda sort of and then again is as I
know I just didn't wanted to deal with
the whole abortion and during a sit-down
with GQ the Bronx native revealed she
and offset will raise their family in
Atlanta quote we're going to build a
house in Atlanta and that's the house
that we're gonna raise our kids in that
same interview cardi B admitted to
getting illegal butt injections when she
was younger
quote it was the craziest pain ever I
felt like I was gonna pass out I felt a
little dizzy and it leaks for like five
days
[Music]